From China's perspective, Taiwan is essentially
a renegade province located roughly 100 miles
off of China's coast, a part of China that
has to be returned by force if necessary.
From the U.S. perspective, however.
While the United States government acknowledges
China's position that the Taiwan is a part
of China, it doesn't recognize or endorse
that position.
Taiwan doesn't have a seat in the United Nations,
and the vast majority of countries around
the world do not recognize Taiwan as a sovereign,
independent country.
The reason for that is because countries cannot
have diplomatic relations with both China
and Taiwan.
They essentially are forced to choose.
Most countries, including the United States,
will choose to recognize the People's Republic
of China and instead only maintain unofficial
relations with Taiwan.
Taiwan has a complex history marked by the
interplay of indigenous groups with colonial
powers from the Dutch to the Japanese.
After World War Two, the Chinese civil war
erupted, pitting Mao Zedong and the Chinese
Communist Party against Chiang Kai shek and
the nationalists.
In 1949, Chiang Kai shek and his followers
fled to the island of Taiwan while Mao established
the People's Republic of China on the mainland.
Mao always sought to reclaim Taiwan and unify
that with the mainland.
While Chiang Kai shek essentially viewed his
government and his regime as a government
in exile, that would eventually take over
the mainland and unify it under his terms,
the Korean War really changed the dynamics.
When President Truman made the decision to
send the U.S. Navy into the Taiwan Strait,
prevent Mao from opening another front while
the United States was fighting North Korea
in the Korean War.
And that really locked in the lines that we
see today from the Chinese Communist Party's
perspective, though, Taiwan is an unresolved
part of the Chinese civil war.
It is a piece of territory that they view
as lost and that should be recovered by force
if necessary.
Taiwan is a pluralistic society, a liberal
democracy.
So saying what 23 million people want is quite
difficult.
By public polling on Taiwan reveals that there
is virtually no support for unification with
China, and there is growing support for independence.
However, Taiwanese people are very pragmatic
and they understand that pursuing independence
is likely to prompt China to use force against
Taiwan to prevent that outcome.
And therefore, most Taiwanese understand that
the status quo is probably the best that they
could hope for, at least for the time being.
And the status quo, as they would define it,
is the Taiwan is a de facto independent country.
It has its own military, it has its own elected
government and currency.
But at the same time it doesn't have a seat
in the United Nations.
And most countries in the world do not recognize
it as an independent country.